[Müzik]
nadiren olmalılar
her neyse
böyle
şimdi
listeyi yayınladığımda kanada'da
bu sayılar
Evet tabi ki
şans en iyisidir
benim gibi
sayısız ve kötü
adres veya tanım olarak
oradan açıkladıklarında
sahip olmak dışında hepsi
elli
[Müzik]
ve dahası var
ve oldum
[Müzik]
Evet
gökyüzünde
Ben
D
Niye
Ah evet
sebebinden beri
bazı bakanlar vardı
kurumlar
diğer şarkı
[Müzik]
benim evimden
Ey
çünkü yorum yapacağız
operasyon olacaktı
şehir
teslim olma emri gibi
ama anlamak
Y
ve nerede
burada olduktan sonra
Bugün nasılsın
konser
biz
Ey
Vay
çıkarıldığı görülmeden önce
olaylar
ama hadi ona daha sonra söylersem gidelim
s
ama herzaman
[Müzik]
iki kaybetmeden
ve kişisel
çalışmasını sağlamak için
şimdi muhbir yayılıyor
ama onlar yeni
şöyle böyle
övmek için görevleri hatırlatılır
Ey
ben hapishaneyim
[Müzik]
bana kendini seviyormuş gibi geliyor
21 yaşında
Y
ama bakıyor
ve bu programlar
ve yılların
Ve öyle değil
büyük popo ve gerçek
onlar havana'da hasar
uyumak için temizlenmişti
olabilir
birbirinizi görmeyi bırakmak dışında sayabilirsiniz
canlı
asma
Ancak
değilse
iyi
hadi ölçelim
için bakanlar olarak
artı
ve eğer o bir kadınsa
[Müzik]
fildişi
ve rüzgarlarından kararlar al
[Müzik]
çok iyi dinlerim
Y
şimdi bir biberin var ne düşünüyorsun
koltuk ve açık fırsatlar
basiret olarak
ve şimdi
veya
milyarın onuru var
uyku
istediğim şey basitleştirilmiş
yetersiz refah artık bir
suç
biden
sen
aşk
genellikle gün ile
[Müzik]
ama başkaları da var
kimin daha iyi olduğunu bil
D
Evet tamam
taktik olarak
farzedelim
Evet
Y
bu seçeneklerden birini bulmak için
onlar zaten var olabilirler hadi gidelim
Y
Evet
bilseydi
sanat sektörü 2002
oturma odasında
yönlendirir
fazla
video
burada göremediğimiz çerçeveyi kullanarak
biden ve tuzlu
Y
kız
ve hepsi buna bağlı
biliyorum rektör ne tartışmaları
ve bölümde seçmek için düşük
Hareketler
çok sayıda
Gerçek olmak
farzedelim
şimdi
Bu görüntülerde
biraz pahalı olsa da
yeterince geldim
başka bir yeni hayat
ama söyleyemem
ama diğer birçok belediye binası
geçmek
temelde herkes
ben değillim
ve ayrıca
Sen olacaksın
şimdi tıklamamız gerekiyor
ve ben
kesinlikle ve köprü
ama sonra
ne kadar büyük olduğunu gördün
pantolon
[Müzik]
3d ekranlar sırasında ve kontrol edin
nihai kararlar
ile zaten başlatılan bir askeri ilişkide
toplum
Bu yüzden sana almam gerektiğini söyledim
esteban andrada istersen
ve ben
bir içerisi var
Diyor
ama bugünlerde
ve hayatta kalmak
Ulusal
şimdi o
Şimdi ben
acıttı
sanat ve daha fazlası
[Müzik]
çocukların olduğu yer burası
durmuyor
göreceğiz
belki bizim değil
Ne için bekliyorsun
ve hayır hayır
Evet
Gördüğünüz gibi
D
onlar yaptı
ne
Evet
Ve bircok digerleri
Biz
[Müzik]
o
del tarafından o saatler için olay için
var olmayan rehber
fiziksel olarak
Ocak ortası
Çünkü eğer
onun annesi
bir
Ikinci için
gelirin
şimdi
ağ
Tamam
kast sistemi ve çok fazla olacakları
olmayan 607 kasabamız
gelenek
daha fazlası için
iyi
[Müzik]
eğer bizim gerçeğimiz
ama önce
kişi
sen olsan iyi olurdu
Hadi gidelim
ve büyük
ve eğer bizim
bir
geç
ve yatırımın olduğunu hissediyorsun
Sahibim
bu gerçeklik
[Müzik]
müşterileri o zamandan beri kaydoldu
başlangıç
vücut ve sonraki bir su yükseltir
denge yanması
diğerleri
ve bugün
bunun anlamı
yerine getirilen 7
Ne
[Alkış]